Well really back up, who has ties with the geek?
Kusa I didn't lock in his people.
They were sent that live during the classes.
They were telling you guys they have ties. Yes.
Dan Lok knew you were homeless during this thing. And yes,
of course you're saying is what made you homeless? Yes.
And he was going upstairs.
I somewhat pause working and I start feeling some pain
in my feet, my shoes,
my socks, and realized actually my feet were bleeding,
HTC family. They GC family. Didn't help you out. There's little family.
I hear you have a, quite the story. Yeah.
Yes, yes. I made an inspirational speaker. I bet. Pell grant.
I'm a civil engineer and uh,
the crazy story start many years ago,
when on a cold night of December,
I was just browsing online on my laptop.
And I came across an odd saying,
learning this new high-income skill will allow you to,
to add six figure income working from anywhere in the world,
only using a laptop and a phone and managing your own schedule,
register for the webinar to learn more.
So I thought this could be a great opportunity.
So as attending the B, I said to myself,
this is definitely a great opportunity.
Now I was very excited and wanted to join the program
right then, and that,
but just like most of people I was facing the most common issue.
I just didn't have enough money to afford the program.
And I was working as a civil engineer,
but all my money was going into my apartment.
It had a nice car and nice lapsed lifestyle. So I thought to myself,
I would just have to catch some asbestos for a few months so I can afford
the program, which was eating at home all the time.
So no more restaurants.
And I was driving a very nice red Mazda.
R is it hard to park my car? No mortgages, no more insurance.
I was walking every day to work or taking the bus.
Oh my God. Wow. That's a heavy sacrifice. Wow. That's crazy.
That's great. Yes. And we make God,
it will maybe take me 10 minutes to get to work.
The boss will take maybe an hour
or sometimes I'll just working.
And few times I will be walking and some coworkers will try to pass
me and give me that smile.
Almost a love heart Cobb.
He cannot afford the scar anymore. Right.
But I knew I was investing in myself. Oh.
I thought I was investing in myself. Sure. So,
and didn't even waste my time explaining to them.
And now at my job, just like all of us at heart,
that one coworker I was more close to than other people.
And I will go to him, talking to him about what I'm working on.
And I talk to him about high ticket closing. He went home,
talked to his wife and came back to me the next morning and said,
this is not a great opportunity.
You are wasting your time and you will waste your money. But I said, no,
you do not understand Danielle. This is a great opportunity.
And I would probably leave my job anytime soon. I'll also still.
So after a few more, after getting some asbestos,
I was not able to invest into this program
on a payment plan.
How much did the total cost of the thing cost? How much was it total?
It wants a lot of money at a loss over 20 K.
First, you have to pay like around $3,000 for the first part of the program.
Then they have an inner circle and they have their event in
Vancouver. You have to fly to that. Exactly.
And then after that, they have created a program that is called,
uh, what's the name, high ticket, high ticket on it.
And that was the worst spot ever. Let me just get to that.
So now I was able to afford this program and I paid for the
program.
I joined the program and every single thing was well
designed. Nothing was left to chest.
Everything looked perfect every single time before Sasha,
I will have my notebook ready, pen it. Glass of water,
not just structure for four hours. It was every single attend.
The program was seven weeks long. And during the program,
they told us that we have to be fully committed to this opportunity to make it
work. So listen very carefully to the following.
People gave up university,
people gave up college,
people gave up the job just for this opportunity because
they told us that we could recruit sister, get income from this opportunity.
At some point at the deceit was just the
worst decision ever. I left my job at [inaudible] just,
this will work. And it was also my fault. I didn't make the right decision.
Now, after the seven weeks,
it was not tired to go out there and to try out
what we just let the worst spot.
At that time, they have collected hammered, harlot,
dozens of testimonials from S we didn't even
try out that skill to understand,
to know whether it works or not, but they gave them.
Clear, clear, here. They captured your testimony.
They got you to say how great the program is before you got to test out the
program.
It's really important. Yes, yes, yes.
Probably somewhere on Dan lock's page saying how great Dan lock-in.
Yes, yes, yes.
We're not even thinking about it. It's just, it's just crazy.
So not to a stat to go out there and to sit and to test the program and the
heart many season for season,
they get them to the seven weeks they graduate and then they have the next
season. After the season,
they clearly realized that these was not working.
People were going to the marketplace, but it was just not working.
They could have peace, the issue by listening, but they decide not to,
during the program, during the classes,
they were telling some people quit trying to speak out because it was not
working, that they have some ties with the Yakuza trickling people.
[Inaudible] back up, who has ties with the geek Kusa.
I then lock.
And his people there were sent that live during the classes
live. They were telling me.
You guys, they have ties with Kusa. So Dalton.
So don't mess with them basically.
No they're saying that's what they think.
So they're attracting people live during the classes,
live during the classes and telling people,
even if we take you out of the program and do not give
you back your money, who cares anyway.
And that's the part that changed everything for me.
And we got to those people that's because, yes,
because it's not because you think
that it above others, that you have to misread that that does not work.
It goes against my values and principles. It just does not work.
And here is another part at the beginning,
eh, even dot and wanted to work for him
that I realized during my life,
I had some very nice job from working with the Canadian government to hobby
an internship with the United nation when I was 18 or 19.
So I have worked at Chris' places. Then I,
that this guy is just a number.
He think no one should speak to him. People should just execute.
He thinks he's an emperor. He's not an emperor, but he thinks he's one.
He thinks he thinks.
So it was now time at the end of the program to go out
there and just test what we have learned from him during the first three
months, nothing. [inaudible] nothing.
And I remember sitting there in my apartment are so upset at
myself. How did I make that decision?
I was not thinking also upset at myself.
I have never been so upset as Pershing the wall. I was really, really upset.
So now after a few months, I couldn't even afford my rent anymore.
And.
Because at this point, you've quit your job. You're trying to sell.
But the sales aren't coming in, like Dan said, they would.
It was not working nothing.
And the weird part is only recently,
we realized just from the news that at some point he
couldn't afford his rent himself. And he always,
he always said he owned that house of 35 million.
And we just relaxed to Haas.
First is only 13 millions. And he never owned that place.
He was renting.
And at some point couldn't even afford to pay the rent.
So whatever you do to others, whatever,
whatever you put out with always come back to you. Of course, of course,
that's the first lesson.
So at that point I couldn't even afford my rent anymore.
So I was now spending some time at some people and new places.
[inaudible].
You were crying with friends or what.
Exactly, exactly.
At where you spend times at some people after a moment you
had nowhere to go.
And I remember on that night was now without arrow
hours without a roof of former in mantra. And it is scored.
It is very cold. I remember on that first night,
I was spending some time at a public place and they closed
that place at midnight or 1:00 AM.
It was not time to close. And the security guy came up to us,
asking us to leave as a pseudo.
I was walking to the door, believe it or not.
I actually remembered, I remembered that I have nowhere to go.
I remember that it had nowhere to go.
So I walked back and I had a seat again.
And somehow they only realize that are still there around 3:00 AM.
The security guard came up, came back. He was very upset. He said,
we closed two hours ago. He was supposed to be gone.
You have to leave right now. I stood up.
I was not half asleep and walk to the door. Came out,
was very cold. It was December already. I look on my right,
look on my left hand. I let just start walking from marijuana on my right.
Then I stop, look back and wet. Finally, on my left,
as I was walking,
I saw this big yellow side of a 24,
seven fast food restaurant. Wasn't make donut also happy.
So I got in all the MSF meal at that
point half hot, some inches I thought are screwed and I can think,
but I just couldn't find any possible way to get myself out of that
situation.
Did you think to go get another engineering job? You're trained as an engineer?
Yeah. I was looking for a job, but it's not that easy to.
Get a job from kitchen job.
And I could just go back to my parents.
I come from very dominant parents.
And as an adult, for me,
it does not work either because I have made some decisions that they will have
never agree with. Never.
So I felt like a hard to go and fix everything
myself. So are there other my meal?
I had a seat and somehow the manager realized something was wrong with me.
He came up to me and he said, no one will take you out here.
We can stay until 5:00 AM at the Metro station nearby open at
5:00 PM. So I got my meal or stare it.
It made me look into the window and accuracy,
the beautiful decoration of Christmas. And you know,
that happy spirit of Christmas. Somehow that spirit got in me.
I was just so happy. Then I tried it M and go and went to that,
uh, to that Metro station. During the day,
I will go to the library reading one or two books every day, sometimes no book.
And one day I left the washroom and as I was working
at suddenly black out to this day,
I still can remember what happened because for the first three days at heart,
really little to no sleep, it was new to me. How do I sleep?
What's as possible.
You're homeless. Yeah.
Yeah. So now very concerned about my health.
I have to figure out a way to get some rest, right?
So when I would go to that fast food restaurant, I would just have a seat,
put both of my hands on the table,
put my head on my hands and sleep until 5:00 AM on scene.
They kicked me out was very,
very embarrassing until they kicked me out during the winter.
And I had nowhere to go at.
HTC family. They, she see family didn't help you out.
There's no family. And there was no family. There was no family.
It was all a story and do not sleep
in that position. My body was hurting. It was awful.
And, uh, on the 25th of December, Christmas,
they had not almost nothing to eat because they had no money left a new
year. I had nothing, absolutely nothing to eat. Nowhere to go.
All the places were closed.
It was so cold that actually my tooth broke into my mouth.
That's how cold it was. It was very cold.
And I thought it couldn't get any worse. Right?
Right. Yeah. That, that's what I would think too.
At some point I was working and I start feeling some pain
in my feet. As soon as I called and horrible,
my shoes grew my socks and realized actually my feet
were bleeding because of the cold. It's just,
just Canada was very cold.
My feet were bleeding and now I thought this was it.
I cannot even work. I have nothing left.
How do I get myself out of this situation?
And that was the place I was in for four months on to you
at, during all this time, they were going after me,
which is very important to see who is going after you then lot and his
people.
So people understand exactly what kind of person he is.
Because our speaking out saying the program does not
work. It just does not work.
And they are going after some of these people who are speaking out,
many people, they are going up.
Dan Lok doesn't like that. Yeah. He doesn't like when people talk about him,
he really doesn't like it. What did he do to you?
They were just trying to, uh, to, to
let and Lincoln,
anytime I will make a connection with people trying to sell some,
our business coaching department.
They are just trying to destroy everything I was working on.
And even sending some people of Emmy,
just to say some bad things about,
You know, the, sorry,
did exactly the same to Kayvon until Kayvon stopped working for him.
And it truly leader should listen and just try to fist to adjust.
But he didn't like that. Sure. It didn't like that.
So he's, he's trying to you professionally.
That's what you allege and your feet are bleeding. You're homeless.
Does he know you're home?
Yes.
Lock knew you were homeless during this thing.
And his course you're saying is what made you home?
Yes, yes. And who was still going after me?
And, uh,
off that happened just because I made that decision to go
through his program. That one decision.
So you were crushing, it let's paint the picture of where you were before.
You're a civil engineer working for the government, working for the government,
making a tidy little living. Nice living. Have a nice car.
You go join Dan Lux course within how many months are you at a point where you
just can't afford rent anymore?
It nine, nine month. So.
It was a nine month kind of process from,
from leaving your job or from Le like leaving, uh, starting the course,
his courses.
From starting to costs. Okay.
So how did he make that $20,000 from you? Because from what I understand,
tight ticket closure is $2,500. What's what else? How much is closures in black?
Probably is pretty expensive. Cause you gotta fly. You gotta rent a hotel.
And then the other one, what is it? Inner circle. How much is that?
All right, so [inaudible] a month. Okay. Yeah. To be part of inner circle.
Okay. Okay.
And some people even lost more money than me.
I've no doubt.
I I've heard that when he was rolling out high ticket millionaire,
people were putting themselves in debt to join. Is that true?
I did the SIM. Wait. Yeah.
You went in debt for high tea.
I thought you said you didn't join high ticket millionaire.
Not like a bit like the Antiope. At some point I had to borrow some money.
I borrow some money at some point.
Oh, I see. I see. During the process of engaging with deadlock,
you had to borrow money at some point. How much did, how much did you borrow?
Well,
the vast majority of people going through that program brought some money.
There were even helping people borrow some money so they can afford that
program. Could you imagine,
do I giving people add yes.
Apart to borrow some money where to get some money so they can afford the
program, which was a scam to start with.
I don't even understand how he has that many upsells.
Because it's just, he got like so many upsells down sells,
cross sells subscription. It was awkward,
but it is very important that I say the following.
It was also my fault for not making the right decision.
I of have thought about it. Ma
do some research maybe so I could make the right decision.
Um, how long has it been since you kind of got your stuff back together?
Uh, since March 7th. So it's fresh. The wound is fresh. Yes.
Yes. I just can't.
And get past the fact that Dan Locke was going,
you say was going after you while your feet are bleeding
because you're, you're broke.
You have no roof over your head and he's still going after you.
Yes. Why would that's who he is? That's who he is. What do you mean by that?
Like we always say you have to do everything to protect
your reputation,
but something that he maybe needs to understand is that in the first
place you have to watch the character as a person.
It is our responsibility to be a good person. So you have a good reputation.
It is not about other people to cover your mistake and your bad character.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, no, no, no. It totally makes sense.
So that's the sorry.
And I hope people learn something from that and, uh,
that did the make a better decision than I did.
I have learned my lessons. It costs me a lot, but I lend it.
I really appreciate you coming on Gill. Um, thank you.
I know even doing this program is a risk to yourself because I know Dan
Locke and you know, Dan Locke and we know how he is.
So thank you for taking,
having the courage to speak out about this man
and what his course did to you. Because as you know,
he's got 2 million subscribers, he's got tons of people joining every day.
And I think you're right.
I'm not sure that they know necessarily what they're getting themselves into.
So hopefully you're a testimonial about the true cost
and experience of Dan's course will,
will help people make a more informed decision. Thank you so much.
It was my pleasure. Thank you.
[Inaudible].